donc considère comme un otage de la
grève vous avez des gens qui se mettent
en grève alors qu'ils ont la sécurité de
l'emploi et ils empêchent ceux qui ont
un emploi d'aller bosser
madame monsieur bonsoir le mardi noir
social était bien au rendez-vous deux
opinions très contrastées résume bien à
l'opinion des uns et des autres
l'humanité titre sur une grève de salut
public alors que le Figaro dénonce au
contraire les fonctionnaires qui mettent
la France en panne la grève étant
annoncée depuis un certain temps chacun
a pu prendre ses dispositions pour
éprouver le moins de désagréments
possible croquis signé Pascal golemer
Philippe des Landes
mardi noir journée galère Paris pagaille
on allait voir ce qu'on allait voir une
victime témoigne
je devais aller bosser je suis pas allé
bosser à cause de la grève parce que
j'ai attendu une heure à peu près des
RER et comme il y en avait pas
finalement on m'a dit de téléphoner à
mon bureau m'a dit de pas y aller donc
je sais pas insisté le soleil aurait-il
un effet magique en bouteillage
dites-vous
parlez-en plutôt au vice-président de
l'Afrique du Sud toussé paraît-il très
bien passé quant aux Parisiens ils se
sont découvert une véritable passion
pour le sport toutes les disciplines et
tous les niveaux sont acceptés avec une
forte très forte domination des
marathoniens
la marche à pied c'est un sport que vous
pratiquez tous les jours ou c'est
exceptionnel
sur la route les adeptes du lèche
vitrine n'ont pas été oubliées les
affaires sont les affaires bonnes
affaires d'ailleurs pour certains
oui l'encombrement aujourd'hui en fait
les gens sont pas venus et je crois que
là c'est c'était valable pour les taxis
pas d'embouteillages et beaucoup de
clients voilà quelques clients quand
même un peu de clients oui voilà merci
un peu de clients l'artisan taxi est
modeste ce fut une chaude journée une
chaude journée d'automne elle est passée
si vite trop vite les Parisiens
retrouvons demain leur train-train
quotidien et la place de la Concorde ses
embouteillages
manifestation un peu partout en province
nous y reviendrons dans un instant le
défilé le plus important a eu lieu à
Paris 100 000 manifestants selon la CGT
20 000 seulement selon la préfecture de
police apparemment quelques-uns ce
serait évaporé au soleil reportage
Sébastien Vibert Michel Levasseur
les fonctionnaires ont beau être en
colère ça ne les empêche pas de faire la
fête ils étaient entre 50 et 100 000
abattre de pavés et le tempo pour clamer
sourire aux lèvres leur mauvaise humeur
quand on parle comme j'entends parler
des fonctionnaires ça me révolte alors
moi c'est pour dire au gouvernement
assez j'ai relativement un bon salaire
j'ai 8000 francs mais il y a l'état de
fonctionnaire c'est 5000 7000 francs
quoi c'est pas on n'est pas des
lentilles quoi et là on est montré du
doigt c'est inacceptable mais si il est
postiers les cheminots les policiers les
enseignants les infirmières étaient si
nombreux aujourd'hui c'était aussi pour
évoquer plus largement l'avenir du
service public et leurs conditions de
travail on a des classeurs chargées des
postes qui sont supprimés c'est sûr on
n'est pas licencié on augmente
simplement la charge de travail en
embauchant moi comment vous voulez qu'on
fuit qu'on puisse correctement faire
fonctionner l'éducation nationale on
souffre d'un manque d'effectif et à côté
de ça il y a des gens qui sont sans
emploi voilà
de leur côté les syndicats n'ont pas
manqué l'occasion on n'avait pas vu une
telle union depuis 1986 et même si le
gouvernement a répété qu'il ne
reviendrait pas sur le gel des salaires
l'année prochaine cette manifestation
aura au moins donné au fonctionnaires un
peu de baume au coeur
si on en prend un sondage et sa publié
par nos confrères du Parisien 57% des
Français soutiennent ou manifestent de
la sympathie pour ce mouvement de
mécontentement bon gré malgré cette
journée sans transport s'est transformée
en galère plus ou moins souriante pour
un certain nombre de banlieues arts
reportage Lucas François-Xavier Bunel
le clair de lune illumine la banlieue
encore endormie ou presque il est un peu
plus de 6h30 du matin quai de la gare
direction Paris désert pour ceux qui
avaient encore quelques espoirs une
affiche est là pour leur enlever tout
illusion et leur confirme que la
circulation des trains n'est pas assurée
en clair débrouillez-vous un banlieusard
parmi tant d'autres Benoît de Pontault
cadres à Paris à trouver une solution il
n'utilisera pas sa voiture mais une
pancarte il affiche la couleur sa
destination c'est l'opéra sa casquette
auto-stoppeur contraint et forcée je me
considère comme un otage de la grève
vous avez des gens qui souhaitent en
grève alors qu'ils ont la sécurité de
l'emploi et ils empêchent ceux qui ont
un emploi d'aller bosser donc moi je
souhaite aller à l'opéra et donc je
précise où je veux aller de façon à ce
que les automobilistes ne perdent pas
leur temps à s'arrêter vous demander où
je veux aller peu de temps perdu sur le
bord de la route 10 minutes auront
suffit c'est l'histoire de
l'auto-stoppeur et de l'auto-stopée tous
deux embarqués dans la même galère
de toute façon j'arriverai en retard et
tandis que nous sommes partis ce matin
il y a un gros trois quarts d'heure
qu'on a fait à peine la moitié du chemin
et qui nous faudra bien
pratiquement le même temps pour arriver
au bureau habituellement le trajet en
train dure 40 minutes et ne coûte que 16
francs aujourd'hui la grève aura imposé
une heure et demie de voiture et 130
francs de parking Monsieur Benoît de
Pontault aura trouvé une solution très
originale pour le retour l'autre côté de
mon panneau et je mettrai au lieu de
mettre opéra et bien je mettrai la
Celle-Saint-Cloud en espérant trouver
une voiture qui me rapproche tout au
moins de La Celle-Saint-Cloud le hasard
et la grève ont finalement bien fait les
choses notre auto-stoppeur cadre dans
une banque a fait la rencontre d'un
auto-stopée cadre dans une société de
finance trafic très perturbé aujourd'hui
sur certaines lignes de la SNCF le
mouvement de grève lancé par 5 syndicats
a été particulièrement suivi il faut
dire que l'inquiétude est grande à la
fois dans le domaine salarial mais aussi
sur l'abandon de ces fameuses petites
lignes non rentables après tout l'un des
slogans de la SNCF après dernièrement le
progrès nouveau que s'il est partagé par
tous Henry Élie
sur les 32000 km de lignes encore en
service fin 94 la SNCF envisage la
suppression de 6000 km d'ici 5 ans et
c'est là l'hypothèse la plus optimiste
exemple dans la région de Clermont si
l'on réduit les lignes locales
considérées comme onéreuses car peu
rentable voici concrètement le résultat
sur cette carte de nombreuses petites
villes ne verraient alors plus de train
passé clairement RIAC Clermont monde
clairement Montluçon dans toutes ces
grandes zones disparaîtraient du réseau
de ferroviaire de la région de
Clermont-Ferrand selon la SNCF la
suppression de ces lignes maudites
permettrait à l'entreprise de faire des
économies un peu partout en France
6000 km de ligne dans des zones peu
denses sont déficitaires elle ne
représente que 1% du trafic et elle
coûte 1 milliard et demi de francs par
an en maintenance autre région autre
exemple à l'ouest derrière cette façade
futuriste de la gare de Rennes l'on veut
là aussi rogner le réseau ferroviaire
breton pourtant déjà peu dense
toutes les relations dites non rentables
seraient supprimées il s'agit donc de
l'axe pouvoir être Lannion mort
l’éroscope aurait Quiberon mais aussi
Rennes Saint-Malo outre les lignes
supprimées les cheminots dénoncent une
remise en cause sévère du service public
même si certains usagers reconnaissent
parfois la faible fréquentation de
certains trains je suis pas loin de
passage à niveau et je vois passer pas
mal de trains qui sont pas si on sent
loin d'être rempli pour ne pas dire
certains sont vides alors ligne maintenu
ou non en attendant il faudra bien un
jour effacer la dette colossale de la
SNCF 175 milliards de francs trafic
quasiment paralysé des voies occupées et
des trains arrêtés en asse campagne les
cheminots ont donc durci le mouvement
aujourd'hui il protestent je vous le
rappelle contre le contrat de plan état
SNCF et contre la réforme des régimes de
protection sociale la table ronde de cet
après-midi à Paris avec le ministre du
Travail n'a rien donné Hélène Frandon
en TGV immobilisé parmi d'autres le
train Bordeaux-Paris a été bloqué
aujourd'hui à Angoulême par 50 grévistes
il rejette toujours en bloc le plan
Juppé sur la sécurité sociale et les
passagers s'impatientent quelqu'un
appelle une manifestation pour
manifester contre les cheminots de la
SNCF parce qu'il y en a marre
peut se permettre de faire
grève qui comprennent bien que les
cheminots aujourd'hui
veulent absolument de défendre
l'ensemble des salariés aujourd'hui un
train sur 6 seulement circulait sur les
grandes lignes et le mécontentement des
cheminots n'est pas prêt de s'apaiser
certes madame hydrak secrétaire d'État
au transport a annoncé aujourd'hui que
les cheminots devraient conserver leur
régime de retraite spécifique
il n'est pas question de remettre en
cause le statut des cheminots
c'est-à-dire ni la sécurité de l'emploi
ni le régime spécifique de retraite des
cheminots mais Jacques barreau le
ministre du Travail lui n'a pas garanti
que ce régime de retraite serait
maintenu dans son état actuel en effet
une commission spéciale va être chargée
pendant 4 mois d'étudier ce régime et
ses perspectives d'évolution d'où la
déception des syndicats reçu cet
après-midi par le ministre encore une
réunion pour rien puisque le ministre
s'est contenté de renvoyer les
organisations syndicales à une
commission qui s'appelle la commission
lovaire si vous me permettez ce mauvais
jeu de mots le verre est dans le fruit
aujourd'hui puisque la question centrale
des retraites
n'est pas abordé par par le gouvernement
il est renvoyé donc à cette commission
je ne vois pas non ces circonstances de
raison pour que la grève sèche dans les
prochaines heures
demain donc sera une autre journée noire
à Paris paralysie totale du trafic SNCF
en banlieue grève à la RATP et
manifestation syndicales sur la rive
gauche en province trafic très perturbé
voire bloqué seul le trafic aérien
devrait échapper à la paralysie
madame monsieur bonsoir avant de faire
le point sur les négociations en cours à
la SNCF et le bilan de la journée
d'action de force ouvrières et de la CGT
la France a vécu une cinquième journée
consécutive de grève datant interminable
dans les gares la tension est montée
d'un cran embouteillage monstre
également autour des grandes villes les
principalement à Paris 25 à 30 km de
bouchons ce matin autour de la capitale
et ce soir une circulation toujours très
dense Richard Fenwick vous êtes dans
votre hélicoptère au-dessus des
principaux axes routiers autour de Paris
absolument bonsoir est-ce que vous
recevez parfaitement et bien parfait
alors voilà la situation de Paris il y a
à peu près 10 minutes c'est ça a tiré un
petit peu viens kiffé la porte
pour la porte de Bagnolet et en passant
par de la chapelle donc de Champerret
vers Bagnolet ça a l'air d'être un
parking total à 86 de Rosny vers le pont
de Nogent c'est à éviter prenez plutôt
la nationale 186 la A86 par le sud de
Thiais vers l'autoroute de l'Est c'est
très très dur autoroute du bien-duc vers
Vaucresson c'est presque au ralenti mais
après votre ressources améliore vers
Rocancourt prenez plutôt la nationale
907 par vos consoles c'est la 118 de
Villa vers 5 lettres pénible et la haine
34 de Vincennes vers l'extérieur est
bloqué d'ailleurs beaucoup de gens ce
soir on prie les Nationales plutôt que
les grands axes
n'hésitez pas forcément le meilleur sur
l'autoroute de l'Est complètement à
l'arrêt du fond de
Joinville jusqu'au pont de Nogent à 15
Gennevilliers vers Sannois rentré et la
A1 l'autoroute du nord de la Porte de la
Chapelle vers La Courneuve est également
très très ralenti l'électricité
[Musique]
Richard pour ses renseignements après
les embouteillages du ciel donc comme
vous les avez vu à l'instant les voici
maintenant au niveau de la route et de
la rue à Paris une véritable journée de
chien Claude son père Christian Routin
Paris la Porte Maillot
il y a une demi-heure
on appelle maximum pour dégager la
banlieue et puis maintenant bon bien on
est saturé
ça part plus
dans un sens comme dans l'eau des
périphériques surchargés et au-dessus
des dizaines de piétons un peu fatigués
de tout ça là je vais tellement être
agressif que ça passera pas à la télé je
suis pour eux de l'autre ça fait chier
début de la grande pagaille 16 heures
des milliers de personnes quittent leur
travail plus tôt et même les feux ici
plaisent de Clichy ils perdent leur
latin vélo stop tout est bon
je fais du stop au fait pour savoir si
quelqu'un peut m'avancer jusqu'à dans le
12e et puis bah je trouve que les gens
sont pas du tout solidaires et vous
regardent comme ça on veut qu'on les
viole je sais pas
un sourire un peu d'espoir et ça marche
dans le métro
il y en aura plus en direction de faire
en direction de chrétaire Créteil nous
allons en départ de Balard qui se passe
à 16h20 et dur dur
au niveau des pieds et tout ça c'est
c'est horrible on peut plus marcher
tellement qu'on en a marre quoi
ras-le-bol
[Musique]
plus grand chose à faire
à moins d'être un roi du patin à
roulettes
courage demain est un autre jour plus
original le recours au bateau-mouche
pour désengorger quelque peu la
circulation dans Paris sur les bateaux
bus les attacher case ont remplacé
progressivement les appareils photos
reportage Marylène Bonnot fabrique
bonnet
Paris avait un petit air de Venise
aujourd'hui les Parisiens qui ne veulent
plus ramer pour aller travailler ont
investi les bateaux bus histoire de
changer de galère le trajet Maison de la
Radio Bercy 5 ou 6 arêtes 19 km allait
retour c'est moins fatiguant que la
marche à pied moins rapide que le métro
et le premier jour on manque un peu de
repère
ça change c'est mieux que le RER où on
enfermé où on peut on voit pas le jour
une heure et demie et 50 minutes de
trajet à 6 km/h minimum 25 minutes
d'attente le bateau bus ne prend qu'une
centaine de personnes c'est une question
de sécurité
pour certains c'est l'occasion de
découvrir ou redécouvrir Paris
chouette ah ouais tu vois on voit pas
tout ça quand on est à pied
j'ai jamais pris le bateau sur la scène
alors au moins merci les SNCF ça fait
des années Jacques dans ça on remet de
transport fluvial a pour eux il a fallu
cette grève pour que ça arrive et
j'espère que ça va continuer
perpétuellement la grève non pas la
grève le transport par bateau alors de
pointe ça se complique de nombreux
passagers restent sur le quai mais c'est
l'attente du bateau suivant ou la marche
à pied ce soir le trafic est fluide sur
la scène peut-être quand même un petit
peu moins que d'habitude
vive la crise c'est souvent le credo des
sociologues qui voit dans les périodes
telles que celles que nous traversons
actuellement l'occasion pour une société
de mieux communiquer et c'est vrai
qu'actuellement on se parle peut-être
davantage on se rencontre un petit peu
plus ça a commencé avec l'autostop et ça
continue avec de belles histoires de
solidarité c'est un peu viens chez moi
j'habite à côté du bureau en tout bien
tout honneur Valérie fournioux et
Jean-Louis Normandin on vérifié
le centre d'affaires de La Défense avec
ses tours son univers de rentabilité et
aujourd'hui ses embouteillages la grève
a quelques peu grippé la machine mais la
solidarité a pris le relais chaque tour
à sa cellule de crise voilà j'habite
tout près de la défense je dispose de
deux ou trois lignes s'il y a des
personnes qui sont intéressées ben aucun
problème moi je je peux les héberger
gratuitement la seule chose c'est que je
fais pas la cuisine
oui je sais pas faire la cuisine mais on
peut commander des pizzas 30 minutes
Antoine a ainsi contacté 12 sociétés de
la défense et de la logique que trois
personnes jusqu'à présent sa proposition
semble trop généreuse pour être honnête
chez nous en fait de réagissent pas ils
ont très peur d'aller chez quelqu'un qui
ne connaissent pas c'est pas quelqu'un
on la demande semble sérieux fait encore
peur les employés de cette société
préfèrent une solidarité organisée par
le groupe comme Roselyne qui a
rendez-vous avec son chauffeur je vais
les retrouver en bas en fait dalle va se
retrouver
toutes les trois que ce soit nous sommes
que trois il y a beaucoup plus de
contacts en ce moment avec les gens
c'est vrai que ça ça se sent il y a
beaucoup plus de solidarité on essaye de
tous s'entraider c'est normal de toute
façon
le chauffeur une employée qui va dans la
même banlieue
[Musique]
est-ce que les gens se parlent plus ah
oui oui
entre deux voitures se demander des
chocolats
ensemble par jour on devient amis
décontractions et fatalisme la grève a
au moins permis aux employés de cette
tour de 4000 personnes de mieux se
connaître de s'écouter de se parler
l'oeil des mauvais jours se lever tôt
pour aller au boulot sans métro avec de
bon godillots
[Musique]
certains marchent quotidiennement une
heure trois quart le matin 1h30
ça marche pas je ne peux pas continuer
comme ça il faut qu'on arrête pas grave
c'est dur
mais on a vu peur que ça si vous aviez
été là pendant que les Allemands étaient
là
ça marchait à la baguette
au malheur des dames les dames qui
possèdent toutefois une botte secrète
le bonheur paraît-il et dans le pré à
Paris il y a seulement des parcs
attention seulement à la frénésie des
grandeurs
on va on voit du pays vous auriez
traversé par si il paye la grève
une heure le matin une heure le soir
c'est pas tellement fantastique pardon
je suis rouge de confusion
je suis fatigué et ça fait trop
longtemps là depuis trois semaines
chaque parisien via son rythme
allez bonne journée
t'en va la cruche à l'eau qu'à la fin et
bien à la fin elle s'habitue 21e jour
d'embouteillage monstre si on calcule
bien ça fait trois semaines d'horreur
sur les routes le moral des Parisiens
est à l'image de leur carburateur
largement encrassé ils sont un tout
petit peu très très très énervé
et j'en ai
marre de la dépression la poussette
un peu excédé un tout petit peu agacé
les trottoirs de Paris voilà à quoi il
ressemble après trois semaines on
fatigue le moral et démoli à Paris on
Molly des mollets la France coupée en
deux il y a ceux qui veulent changer la
société et ceux qui se contentent de
changer des roues cela au moins font une
bonne affaire cette boutique fait chaque
semaine l'équivalent d'un mois de
chiffre d'affaires on n'a jamais vu
rouler autant d'authentique antiquité
alors tout va mal il est né la même date
que moi c'est-à-dire en 1961 et il est
fatigué il est fatigué et il n'est pas
le seul au bar autour du zinc on n'a pas
un moral en acier ça n'empêche même plus
de voir rouge s'envoyer un petit blanc
les conversations sur la grève ça fait
combien de pour cent des conversations
qu'on a dans ma journée en ce moment à
Paris je sais pas si c'est tous les
jours mais c'est le matin au moins et le
soir j'entends pas
la subit c'est ça exactement aux abords
de l'Elysée les forces de l'ordre
bloquent les circulations remarquez ça
fait elle était déjà bloquée mais s'il
est vrai que Paris vaut bien une messe
alors Sarajevo vaut certainement un
embouteillage même si les Parisiens en
ont assez que Sarajevo soit à deux
heures de Notre-Dame et Versailles à 4
heures de Paris madame monsieur bonsoir
la tendance à la reprise s'est amplifiée
aujourd'hui à la SNCF ou la CGT la CFDT
est forte ouvrière ont appelé sous des
formes diverses à la suspension du
mouvement suspension votée par une
majorité d'assemblées générales au dire
même de la Fédération CGT des cheminots
exemple au dépôt du Mans que nous avons
suivi tout au long de ce mouvement
durant trois semaines reportage Jacques
cardoz Nathalie Gallay
le regard est encore tourné vers
l'assemblée générale mais seulement pour
quelques minutes car ce matin au Mans le
ton a changé
la lettre du ministre des Transports les
cheminots du monde n'attendait plus que
ça pour mettre fin à 22 jours de conflit
le projet de contrat de plan état SNCF
est gelé les engagements du Premier
ministre sont tenus on procède alors au
vote pour la reprise du travail qui est
pour la suspension de mouvement que nous
avons engagé depuis 22 jours
hésite encore mais ici aux ateliers
comme au dépôt pour le personnel roulant
on a remis les clés au chef
d'établissement
en espérant que vous n'avez jamais aller
utiliser pour le fermer le travail va
donc reprendre et visiblement dans la
bonne humeur
[Musique]
ému mais déçu quand même parce que je
pense qu'on a pas été suivi par par la
majorité des Français c'est dommage mais
bon je crois que c'était un train à
prendre en marche ils l'ont pas pris
tant
pis à tous
mais bon on a sauvé les meubles du choix
quand même au niveau de la SNCF
autre préfère avancer des problèmes
financiers et une maigre fiche de paye
après 23 joueurs de grade vous êtes un
masque vous savez un couple avec une
femme qui travaille à mi-temps même moi
qui travaille ici à la SNCF c'est très
dur de on a de moins en moins de loisirs
on fait de plus le plus pour les impôts
et tout on n'arrête pas de donner de
l'argent alors c'est très dur
oh là là la matinée se termine par une
haie d'honneur les non grévistes
défilent devant les grévistes un
cérémonial plutôt étonnant reste comment
la plupart des cheminots ont bien repris
le chemin des ateliers
exemple de reprise encore timide et
partiels du trafic ferroviaire dans le
Nord où cet après-midi un premier TGV a
pu relier Roissy à Lille un TGV
pratiquement vide faute d'information
reportage amour Tommy masse un simple
train qui roule cela prend parfois à
l'allure d'un événement ce TGV est le
premier à rentrer en gare de l'île
depuis trois semaines un symbole alors
logiquement l'erreur voyageurs qui l'ont
emprunté sont ravis vous êtes content
d'avoir pu prendre le train très très
parce que je vais à la fac pour un
passage de thèse
je suis très contente comme j'imagine
les autres dizaines de passagers
[Musique]
le TGV j'espère que ça va reprendre très
vite aujourd'hui 6 allées retours Lille
Roissy quelques trains régionaux
celui-là va même en Belgique et chacun
retrouve vite ses petites habitudes le
plaisir de regarder le paysage ou de
lire le journal
tranquillement car les wagons sont
déserts peu de voyageurs est informé de
la reprise du trafic en passant à la
gare j'ai vu sur le tableau d'affichage
et
j'ai demandé à quelqu'un qui m'a
confirmé ne serait par hasard sur
au fil des heures la gare de Lille
s'anime devant les guichets les fils
d'attente se reforment les grilles à
cumulées pendant 3 semaines resurgissent
je viens de faire rembourser pourquoi
pourquoi parce que quand j'ai voulu
apprendre le train justement j'ai pas pu
l'utiliser et je dois me faire la queue
pour être remboursé c'est quand même
terrible demain sur le tableau
d'affichage quelques trains en mais
avant d'être sûr de ne pas composter son
billet pour rien il faudra attendre au
moins 8 jours
[Musique]